un silence étouffant
suffocant même
juste le bruit du feu et du vent
l'aviation russe a lâché une bombe sur
ce village de bil au gorille fca à l'est
de l'ukraine
ici c'était une école
90 civils pensaient y trouver un abri
sûr
un soldat ukrainien film les décombres
et a du mal à cacher sa colère
il ya très peu de survivants
salle aux russes
selon qui a filé à 60 morts les rescapés
sont sonnés
j'ai été mis au sol par l'effondrement
d'une dalle je me suis recroquevillé
puis il ya eu une autre explosion
des pierres sont tombées au puy les
ténèbres j'ai ouvert un oeil à travers
la poussière j'ai vu un rayon de lumière
sergei a rampé et m'a aidé à sortir puis
on a déterré mon oncle ma tante on a
rampé dans le nuage de poussière
cet homme lui est trop affecté pour
trouver les mots il vient de perdre sa
mère
et ce bombardement est loin d'être une
exception
les territoires du dombass encore aux
mains des ukrainiens mais convoité par
les russes sont sans cesse pilonné ces
derniers jours